حالتان مقلقتان متشابهتان بشكل مخيف
يؤججان المزيد من المؤامرات حول نظام بوتين
في غضون 24 ساعة هذا
الأسبوع
تم العثور
على اثنين من المديرين التنفيذيين الروس السابقين الأثرياء مقتولين مع عائلاتهم يوم الاثنين ، فلاديسلاف أفاييف
، تم العثور على زوجته وابنته ميتين في
شقة أفاييف في موسكو روسيا
أخبار الدولة  وكالة تاز نقلاً عن مصدر في
إنفاذ القانون يقول إن السلطات
تحقق في الحادث باعتباره
جريمة قتل وانتحار في اليوم التالي
، وجدت زوجته وابنته
ميتين في منزلهما في منتجع بالقرب من
برشلونة إسبانيا.
من المحتمل أن تكون ابنتي قد قُتلت
داخل منزل بروتوسينيا الفاخر الذي عثر عليه
ميتًا في الحديقة بالخارج عندما
يموت رجال الأعمال الروس ،
أعتقد أن نوعًا ما يجب أن يفترض
الأسوأ أولاً ، أعتقد أن هذه الوفيات في
كتابي مشبوهة للغاية
لأنها متشابهة جدًا وهم
كلا الشخصين البارزين
الذين جنا أموالهم في قطاع النفط والغاز
إذا كان هؤلاء متخلفين  يمكن أن
يكون هؤلاء الرجال تحت
ضغط مالي بسبب تداعيات الحرب الأوكرانية ،
فنحن في لحظة تعليمية للغاية في
روسيا المال نادرًا
ما يتعرض كل أنواع الناس
لضغوط كثيرة ، ولكن هناك الكثير من
النظريات التي قد يكون هناك أشخاص  في روسيا
المرتبطة بالأجهزة الأمنية التي
لا تحب الأشياء التي يفعلها هؤلاء الأفراد
، يمكن أن تكون
أنماطًا من الانتقام ضد
الأفراد الذين قد يتعاونون
مع السلطات الأجنبية أو الأشخاص في
روسيا الذين لا يريدون
مشاركة معلومات معينة
ما هو غير واضح ما إذا كان فلاديسلاف
عرف أفاييف وسيرجي بروتسينيا بعضهما
البعض أو تواصلوا مؤخرًا مع بعضهما
البعض ، ويقول المحللون الذين تحدثنا إليهم
إنه ليس من الواضح ما إذا كان أي من الرجلين قد
تحدث ضد فلاديمير بوتين أو الحرب في
أوكرانيا هل كان من الممكن أن يكونا مستهدفين من قبل
بوتين نفسه.
تحت بوتين
لاتخاذ إجراءات ضد الأشخاص
من تلك
الرتب المتدنية ، ليس ما يفعله هو
ما يفعله عادةً هو ثنائية
لا يزال بعض الخبراء يقولون إنه إذا كانت هناك
لعبة شريرة ، فلن تكون هذه هي المرة الأولى بين
أباطرة الأعمال الروس ، من أجل تقديم مثال للراحة
وترويضها والسيطرة عليها.  الوفيات في الخارج
سنشهد المزيد من الضغوط بين
النخبة لأن هناك الكثير من الشكوك
والاتهامات المتبادلة في روسيا